would you be devastated if your mom beat
you no
you'd be happy for her i would
definitely be happy for her the best win
is if she wins it's true listen i get it
like like my son gets a base hit in
baseball and i think i like won the
nobel peace prize
i do fully understand the parent thing
now
comma if i was playing baseball against
my son i'd want to strike his little ass
out vayner nation what's good uh really
excited to do another live episode i
know you guys get a whole bunch of
content from speeches and and kind of
recordings but in studio back in the
office in new york with
one of my favorite families on earth
the millios are here all four of them
that always makes it the most fun
i actually somebody cut up uh for
tick-tock our first meeting and it
showed up in my stream and it just made
me smile so hard i saw it a couple days
ago and made me think about how much
this family has
been through from a huge rise to
awareness all sorts of things we'll get
into that of what they're up to now but
you know i'll just say it because i
believe in and i know they know how i
feel about them but i'll say it publicly
i am fascinated by something i believe
more than anything which is i truly
believe that money and fame
does not change people i believe that it
exposes people i think what you are gets
supersized in those environments and
from the day we met in this office not
in this room but a couple steps over to
this exact second my most favorite part
besides the fact that the world got to
know them
is that what i sensed that day when we
hung out has become absolutely true
which was i left saying oh [ __ ] i
actually think they'll be okay
which was so foreign because
the last three or four years what i met
people
in that pre-dawn of what i thought would
be the moment
where they would get really famous and
known i would always be concerned
especially when people are so young
that the parents would get caught up in
the hoopla and and that naturally
happens because everyone gets dragged in
but
when a family is like built on actual
love and caring for each other even
through the toughest times where you can
get caught up in the subconscious of
what's happening in the macro
it's still gonna be okay
and uh that's my favorite part about u4
i always know you guys are gonna be okay
with each other which really kind of
like makes me just cheer for my favorite
part actually is i think it's a
blueprint that i hope other families
that are gonna go through their moments
you know tick tock's just the latest for
me of the last 15 years there's going to
be the next platform it's going to
happen might be three years six years
and there's going to be a charlie on
that platform and and i think it'll be
cool that that family
that's affected by that opportunity has
you to look at as a framework so it's
really nice to see you for
thank you thank you
what's cooking
you go first here and mom wow um
i guess our
latest thing that we've announced has
been
my mom and i competing against each
other on season 31 of dancing with the
stars which is massive disney plus so
that is very fun and is that when does
that start to air
september 19th so soon yeah
and disney pla like is that not an abc
anymore or it's abc and disney plus or
how does it work now so they're moving
for the first time i love that
i mean i personally love that because in
adland which is where we're at here at
vaynermedia
i've been waiting for the death of tv
commercials
and and i always thought it was going to
be social which i was wrong it ended up
being streaming and just hearing even
that which i was unaware of until this
second like continues to reinforce where
i know this is all going very cool so
that's cool
so let's just get right into it because
i think competition is the coolest thing
on earth
do you think you guys will get chippy
about this like will there be emotions
when one of you gets eliminated will the
other person be happy or like where are
we at i mean obviously you should be the
heavy favorite given that's like your
identity like you're actually epic
dancer mom i have no clue where you sit
in this world i don't know if she took
your dna or what i was a competition
dancer okay so this is going to actually
be interesting but i haven't done it in
over like yeah but it's like
but it's like riding a bike right
forever ago
i hope it's like riding a bike
i think
would you be devastated if your mom beat
you no
you'd be happy for her i would
definitely be happy for her
i
am aware
of the competition aspect and i've
watched the show so i know
what sometimes you might get your best
style and i might get my worst and
that's just how the week rolls out and i
get out and then i get to still go and
watch her so
it's
kind of a win-win for me because at
least i'll still
one of us is going to get out first and
whoever that is
really i think it's more of a win-win
for you oh for sure because she's the
heavy favorite
like but
forget about being a mom no no don't
forget about that like yeah well i know
that's a weird thing it's like obviously
i want to talk about competition not
like humanity i want to win i do i want
to win but like the best win is if she
wins like as a win win for
it's true listen i get it like like my
son gets a base hit in baseball and i
think i like won the nobel peace prize
i do fully understand the parent thing
now
comma
if i was playing baseball against my son
i'd want to strike his little ass out
you're super competitive it's going to
get but you're different like he would
be more like that like i don't care i
will take it i will take out me what
about you no i'm saying if you're going
against one of us it would
it's like i'm gonna win where her i feel
like oh it doesn't matter who it is
we're also both going to
put all of our effort into it and try
our best to win so it's not like she's
going to hold herself back
no that i believe i asked charlie if she
if they both were going into the final
if if she would pull back a little bit
she said you you know me right
absolutely
so they're going to go pull forward
that's
so embarrassing who else it will speak
about
do they i assume they announced
everybody
okay i'm excited to see that that's
awesome what else is going on you guys
have like literally 700 000 things going
on at once which is
my favorite zone to be in so i
understand why it's fun and interesting
like what else has been brewing cat you
know a lot of people in this audience
that are listening have followed the
journey of our relationship so they've
seen the steps
you know
but a lot of people are busy it's been
the summer so people are kind of in
their family zones what's been going on
in
this empire the last six months well we
start season two of our show the demilio
show comes out uh september 28th and
that
i'm really happy about it i think it's
going to show
the first season
was in the midst of covid and it was
kind of showing us our first
few months out in l.a i consume so
little content like uh that is like long
form so meaning like all i do for a
living is really hence how we know each
other like watch everything that's going
on in social to figure out what i need
to do as a strategist in business
but obviously because of my deep love
for you guys i got to watch like
several i'm trying to think i think i
watched at least three or four which is
unheard of like that's about besides
never have i ever on netflix you know is
like like i really have consumed so
little content and what i took away from
season one is that
i love noah
everyone
yeah no but yes that was like there was
knowing obviously what was going on in
actual real life and then watching those
first three or four episodes being able
to kind of contextualize the timing of
when you were filming
it was an interesting time of like
transition for you guys in a lot of ways
when the filming was actually probably
very good for like television purposes
because there was a lot of real changes
and feelings going on in your family's
lives i'm i'm actually i'm curious how
season two it it it probably will have a
pretty different tone
yeah it's
you go no you go i mean i feel like
season two is more
like okay we're in this we're doing this
there's no going back kind of thing
whereas with season one you're like how
it like there's that subconscious of
like what's this gonna be like yeah yeah
could we just
go back of course
of course
i mean interesting for me
to
kind of see all the concepts of what
we've actually done in the past year or
so um but i think it's just
you see so much
and you get to see so much
more in a very happier
in a much happier
kind of environment where
you see us really work together because
this is the time where it can die out
you know like this isn't going to last
forever so you really get to see us have
fun with our work and go into a little
bit deeper well you know what's funny
about you guys like and obviously like i
i know a little bit more under hood but
it's like listen you guys are busy i'm
busy it's not like i know everything i
think the reason
i've always felt that it wouldn't die
out was it was similar to me when i
first kind of hit the scene on twitter
in 2067 i have such a ridiculous
over-the-top energy personality that
everyone's take was oh this is going to
be like a six-month thing like to my
face let alone behind my back
it was and i remember thinking
you know obviously having confidence but
it wasn't even about that it was oh they
don't understand that i'm a businessman
and that like i'm not here for like the
like party i'm like here for the thing
and
you know obviously all four of you are
different you're all in different places
in your lives but the thing that i
always knew and then obviously as you
guys know i knew greg from a million
years ago with the lonely girl like
nobody on earth knew what youtube was me
and him did
so i was like oh look at that move and
so like for me
it's funny even when you said it now
it's why i jumped in it's like
you you four will do it as long as you
enjoy the behind the scenes part
not
the part of like instant fame not into
fame like yours is predicated on the
behind the scenes work
and you'll decide when you're not
interested in that or interested in that
all separately you got you guys are so
young you may do something else you'll
always want to do it you'll like you
know like it's kind of like it's just
different
i feel like we all are
mostly interested in the business well i
see that this is kind of
like we all enjoy it and every time
we're in those meetings it's the most
fun and we still do like the content
stuff but
that kind of
literally back to like the meta of this
conversation and back to me catching
some episodes the single favorite thing
from everything i saw was the meeting
that greg was trying to have in the like
movie theater room about like your
schedule charlie and like just like like
i i liked it because i'm like that's a
meeting
that's like my life it's a meeting and
you're like [ __ ] do i have a minute to
do this or why do we have to go to that
or you know and so like i get that i
sense that how's the music stuff going
good i did a tour this summer
um and then i kind of took a little bit
of a break and
what's been the what's been the hardest
part and what's been the most enjoyable
part
you know i know you knew
like
going into this genre was going to come
with all sorts of different things
music's like a rough one
you know like what ended up being way
harder than even your very thoughtful
like this is gonna [ __ ] suck [ __ ] it
sucked more and then on the flip side
what did you think you were gonna like
and it's even like better than you
thought
um
writing is definitely for me
like this is a totally personal thing
writing and getting my emotions into
songs was very difficult for me because
i was so no one cares no one cares about
what i'm feeling or i'm sad this day and
that's a i don't want to say regret but
i do regret not putting that into my
album and like my dad was like you
should do that you have a story to tell
you're not doing that i'm like no it's
fine and then i ended up doing like a
bunch of like
breakup songs or just random filler
songs that are really cool and fun for
the kids but it's not me so
now i'm looking back like i should have
done that for moving on like that's what
i'm going to do yeah but performing is
the best part of all of it like oh crazy
the amount of adrenaline and sure
love it good for you i had a great time
doing that but no i definitely know for
the future i just people want to hear
that like as much as you think no one
cares there are someone who like
wants to hear that people have shared
experiences
just the way it is pops what's going on
with you
we're having fun man you know we just
you're talking about
i was you know i was in the
clothing business and we decided we just
launched a brand company so
we took uh investment we got some great
investors and we started a company
called emilio brands we announced it
yesterday and it's going to be things
that we
incubate and own 100 percent with our
investors
michael michael rubin's an investor with
us and we have a great group of people
um and we've opened an office in
hollywood and
we're starting first launches we're
bringing our merch over to this so we
have a nice revenue stream uh into the
company and their second is launching a
women's footwear company women's
footwear yeah i mean i think you know
when i wrote crush it
i kind of talked about the concept of
like you can make money being on the
internet and like if you go read the
first 50 reviews on amazon people are
like you're gonna laugh at this one
literally one of the comments is like
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna make a
hundred thousand a year on youtube like
that's how crazy it was in 2008
but you know obviously
and one of the biggest reasons i started
vayner was the concept of
cpgs consumer package goods i've already
started one and sold one with empathy
wines
you know when i saw that coming down the
pike
that's if we're talking like if you know
this is a business podcast and as it
touches on other things but like that's
the big one that's the elephant in the
room like if you nail one
the toothpaste the shampoo
the deodorant the footwear like one one
item in that category
that's the empire building and we want
to be really thoughtful about the
products and the categories and what
we've learned is
you know charlie moved the needle for
invisalign the ceo came out and said
one quarter in 2000 their market kept 95
and then
dunkin donuts sold out i remember cold
brew so we we can move move the needle
but we don't want to get into just
doing
i actually think you're also in a better
spot now than even because charlie not
being in the singular most white-hot
moment of her career
is actually a good thing like i'm sure
that it's harder for charlie knowing how
social plays and like how the world
works to sell as much
duncan in a day as that perfect moment
where she's at but in a year she can
sell more it's like a very interesting
curve that people don't understand right
it's like and i actually think that that
is a huge benefit for how you're going
to be because what it does is it doesn't
trick you into the ease of it
like it's kind of how i'm thinking about
v friends i like that crypto's ice cold
right now because the depth gets to show
up versus people buying people were
buying porcupines with cigarettes up its
ass for 400 000 that wasn't sustainable
and like
from from madonna to you know lebron
everybody has different peaks and
valleys of their mass popularity and i
think it's actually healthy that you're
in this zone the mature what i call a
mature zone to like do it for your own
stuff yeah
and we don't and what's great about is
we can do it we have the show and and
they have all they're still doing
endorsement deals so this is something
we can incubate take our time when i
first started my first clothing brand
heidi was pregnant and it was all about
making the money and we kind of didn't
have some of the decisions i made were
you had to feed dicks in a position of
you know in a position of fear of course
we're in a position now where we just
wanted to do the right thing and create
cool brands you have the luxury of
patience 100 000
charlie what's going on with you and
content obviously so much of this
started with you making content
what's your
couple things what's your observation of
like the social media landscape from a
content standpoint not like
political this or that just like just
like what you're seeing what you're
interested in and then number two on a
personal level like you the human
where are you in your
interest to make content and where and
how and what
so for me i would say
at a time where i could have really
you know i could have
done everything and posted 24 7 and i
instead took a step back and stopped
posting as much and i think
i think that
that was a good thing because now i
am getting back into it and i'm not
feeling burnt out and i'm feeling
excited to make content again and even
though that might have hurt me then this
is going to help me in the long run
because i'll be able to make content for
longer and do the dances and do all the
fun stuff and make videos with my
friends but it took that little bit for
me to then be able to do this for
years and years and years and
obviously watching still always watching
what's going on on each platform and
what's working well and what's not i do
obviously pay attention to that because
that's important
but also
listening to
the people that are watching and seeing
what they enjoy seeing from me and what
types of content they like they
obviously still love the dances and when
i do them that's super fun i don't do
them as much
but getting back into it a little bit
more now
and
i think
social media especially tick tock as a
platform has changed a lot in
what you see it's
a little bit more
people's videos blowing up one and then
it kind of dying out a little bit
instead of people that are on your 4u
page 24 7
obviously i'm very lucky to have a
strong fan base that will watch all of
my videos and comment on them and i'm
very lucky for that but that doesn't
happen for anyone so i haven't seen too
many people
get that kind of blow up everyone's
watching them for longer than like
a week or two i think the only people
right now or
these group of those triplets
yeah and they
are on youtube
and
so their videos are people are watching
their youtube and then on tick tock but
those are the only people that i think
have blown up recently well what about
this adorable corn kid
no but i mean like to your point what
you're actually breaking for everyone
who's listening what you're speaking to
is and this is why
my career has been
yelling at the top of my lungs when
there's the moment to land grab
attention
you were part of an era and some of your
friends
no different than the vine crew from
four years earlier who are still
relevant logan batch many others
you could have sustained crazy growth
you were in that era where one video
went viral but then it was like build
build build build build now
every person on earth is producing for
the platform multiple times a day and
it's supply and demand even though
there's so much more attention on tick
tock than it was when you started the
amount of content has outpaced
that attention and the rise of micro
influencers as well going side by side
of course it's supply
you know if there's four million people
producing for tick tock at the time when
you're doing it and now there's 400
million that's going to lead to more
micro because everyone's getting 25 000
views instead of fewer people getting 4
million views it's just the same old
game
and that makes a lot of sense what i
really liked
like one thing that people forget about
in my career is i made content every day
five days a week doing the wine show for
five years monday through friday and
then when i got serious about
vaynermedia i barely made content from
2011 to 2014 because i was fully
operating
and i remember when i started back up
and did the askgaryvee show
how pumped i was to do it
and how much i dragged the last hundred
episodes of wine library tv
uh obviously a bigger window in a
different format but i can really relate
slash it's a good piece of advice for a
lot of people listening right now
you know maybe you aren't blowing up to
the same level that charlie did but if
you're feeling stale or tired
yes i believe that you should take
advantage of the opportunity of making
content but if you're not looking
forward to it you need to either take a
break or change up what you're making
to that point because i think this will
help a lot of people has it been fun to
watch your audience mature with you
absolutely i think
turning
into an adult in front of
all of these people
while they were turning into adults it
was very weird for a lot of my fans at
the beginning when i started
you know i got my first tattoo or did
whatever that was that was so foreign to
them because i had been so you know sure
pictures you were never like family
friendly yeah and that's i think we all
no none
but like in a good way we were like i
was cursed or
did me
yeah different dance moves or something
so it wasn't like a surprise it wasn't
like i was more i was surprised when
your nails started being like 17. i know
um but i think i was more worried about
what they were going to say but i also
have to understand that's fair when i
was 15
they were they could have been 15 now
they're 18 with me of course so they're
doing the same thing of course
obviously and even by the way the the 11
and 12 and 13 year olds when you were 15
are now 15 16 17 you know like yes
so it definitely helps that they're
growing up with me because it helps me
understand them as much as it helps them
understand let's make some content
that's going to help the next crew on
the next platform that they can look to
for you too and from mom and dad because
i know you're observing this because you
love your children more than anything
the 30 of you that's 80 of you you two
represent a crew of about 150 or so that
were part of that era addison no like oh
like that crew
i've always been fascinated by that i've
always watched that even from like
[ __ ] myspace of like dane cook and
tila tequila talking about [ __ ] five
years after they blew up on myspace
there's these crews i had it with like
tech nerds on twitter because that was
so tech nerdy just like all these years
later we're still have friendships
they've evolved a lot of our band got
back together again with web 3 after not
talking for a while
give a little insight to the evolution
of like the relationships the crew like
who burns out and moves back home from
la
like like just some of the subtleties
that may help for somebody in seven
years when they listen to this because
they're part of that 150 person group on
the new platform puzzle that has taken
over the world like what are some of the
dynamics the watch outs the interesting
stuff i mean it's sure it's like cliche
high school stuff of like who you trust
and all that but are there any like
unique insights or anything that you
find fascinating or like a scenario or
like a for instance that you find is
cool of like these two people decide to
do this or anything like that i think
what's really surprising is how many
people took advantage of the opportunity
like in a good way yeah yeah
like
no one
everyone moved to la like at the same
time there was probably
200 kids who all came to l.a at the same
time which i
i mean i watched viners and youtubers
and they would stay home for years
building this but because it was so fast
everyone just got there and and you all
had the benefit of seeing
like logan's career through vine
gave you a preview of what could be
which led parents
the the parents of a generation earlier
is like you're not going to [ __ ] l.a
this is vine whereas for your parents
there was at least proxies of being like
well this is something we have to debate
because it may be a real thing no
different than like going to college to
play professional sports to get to the
league
the reason that
so many people that were
you know at the same time as us doing
the same things we were all making
videos together it was it was very much
this whole big group of people of course
and
a lot of those people also have since
done things
in very positive ways to kind of put
themselves out there and a lot of on
different platforms doing podcasts
making brands making products
movies acting singing all of that stuff
i think we have a
really we came up with a really good
group of people that
all do you think you also do you think
you guys also did a good job curating
the people you stayed close with
absolutely i think it's
obviously now better than when i was 15.
of course um
i don't know i'm friends with everyone
yeah like we i if i see someone even
i don't talk to them well i think yeah i
think there's a difference but like
listen i'm the same like the thought of
like disliking someone is so foreign to
me but to the point of like there's a
difference between an acquaintance
yeah a half a queens half
lightweight friend a lightweight friend
a core friend a best friend right i
think for me i have a lot of people that
i like a lot of people that i care about
a lot of people that i consider friends
maybe text more than i see
but i really only hang out with like
three people i guess i think our if
we were
like wanted to do this and did more
business moves with the other creators
it would have been amazing yeah i
totally get it we should have been doing
more
youtube videos together more collabs and
stuff like that what about to really
help a lot of people here the parents
ecosystem what did you what's your
observation several years and now of
maybe the watch out for the parent
that's listening right now that in four
years their kid goes from zero to four
million on puzzle in a week by the way i
really hope puzzle happens
what did you see was the cliche misstep
that isn't the obvious one of like they
just cared about the money and they
didn't care about their kids like was
there any subtleties or an insight or
something that was like an interesting
observation along the way i have one
please just yes daughter good you have
to
allow your parents to still be your
parents and instead of being a friend or
a buddy who will do you feel like some
of your friends because they were making
so much money
it changed the relationship and they
were [ __ ] on their parents and not
allowing them that breathing room yeah
it makes sense you still need to be able
to go to your parents and talk about
normal
things and i was in trouble yeah get in
trouble have to clean your room do all
those things um ask for your parents to
drive you everywhere like you still have
to have that relationship with them like
that's why i would never want them even
though i think i think you could be an
amazing manager he would never do it i
would never want him of course it
changes the dynamic but i will still go
to him and of course
because he cares about me more than
anyone i get it i think our biggest
thing was
i am old enough to have heard all the
horror stories of dads and moms getting
involved and i think what i would say
like those 80 sitcoms like right right
like gary like gary coleman and like
webster and like and as good as i was as
as far as in the apparel industry it
didn't some things translate to
hollywood and most things don't and i
knew starting my own clothing brand i
used to constantly try to do things on
my own and i would waste time and we
early on just put experts with us we
hired business manager top attorney in
la and greg obviously getting greg to
come over from uta to be president of
our company so i would tell parents no
matter how smart how many things you
have and how smart you are
lean on an expert and i would say get
involved really don't don't look at it
like oh that's just something the kids
are doing like get involved as much as
your kids will let you get involved
yeah i mean i kind of just to piggyback
with charlie said i think when you're
you know as a parent your kid starts
making more money than you it sort of
puts the relationship off balance
and um i mean we also have always said
like i love them more than anything i'm
not your friend i'm your parent yeah and
we never we never switched up on that
right you would like smack dicks in the
face if you
well not that but you know i don't know
i think we need to have a real debate in
society about i think spanking
going away might have changed honestly
i'm not joking the best part about
having your parents
be your parents when they're when you're
on social media is they only thing they
couldn't do is
take the phone which is good
what uh what else before we get out of
here what did we not touch on anything
else like anything worth
speaking on um i would say for me the
other thing that's been a very big part
of my life that i've worked on for a
really long time and is doing very well
is i came out with my own fragrance yep
and that was my first brand completely
on my own yep and
[Music]
that
took a very long time a lot of work and
while i wasn't posting and making
content that was something that i was
working on a lot are we going to see
that in season two a little bit or not
that's cool you got to see pretty much
the whole journey is it out yet yes and
how'd you do it like where do you sell
it through it's sold in ulta beauty yup
exclusively for right now
ulta beauty and morphe stores yeah
looking for international necks okay
something that i'm working with do you
do a lot of in-store appearances or no
um not as much in-store appearances did
you do any yes and was it crazy
there wasn't people there we didn't tell
them because we were filming it just for
my own content um but i definitely do
leave it out and
yeah i went to france i got to go to the
labs there
i got to go to
the office in new york and
really be through the whole process and
be there and be a vocal and they
listened to me and that was really
awesome
and then i did a little influencer event
smaller just with really my friends and
family for the fragrance launch and that
was really fun
but
it's doing very well i'm very proud of
it that's something that i put a lot are
you excited about the whole brand with
that experience now that you're gonna
have your own ecosystem or like if i
said like what's one product before this
is said and done that you think you'll
want to make in this ecosystem what
would it be i think a candle with the
same scent
nicely
actually i want to ask all of you that
if if now you've got this thing you'll
be thinking about the consumer products
obviously the women's footwear brand but
like thinking out give us something fun
just for our own like what do you think
is a weird product a weird one not the
obvious one that you think you like
like might want to do
well for me i have like this thing of
like
and there's a lot in my life of like the
perfect white t-shirt and the perfect
sock that doesn't slip down so like
simplicity functions the whole thing of
like things that i'm searching for in my
life
selfishly yeah i know other people have
to be feeling the same i like that dog
products dog yeah
it's a big market gary i'll say one
thing which i know you're you're a dad
and through this whole experience and
why we're doing the brands thing you
know to say all the parents out there
there's been so many times i've said
something with my kids and they've
either rolled their eyes or they've been
like whatever whatever but to see both
charlie and dixie in business meetings
and then knowing they got something from
me or heidi so i i would say to parents
don't stop being parents and if they're
they are listening whether they're of
course
especially when your [ __ ] ends up being
true
like i see it at my in my forget about
kids in my company like they constantly
roll like their eyes
this company after all the things i was
right about laughed at me for tick tock
like no they're they're always listening
and i think to your point this is where
parents have to be very careful when you
just say [ __ ] that you're not fully
confident in and you're listening to
other parents for parents you're
listening to your parents not yourself
and not looking at your kid
if if you're if you're gonna say
something
and then it ends up being wrong
like for all the parents over the last
15 years that told their kids
get off social media you'll never make
money on that and then all these people
did
you're gonna have a problem
for them to listen to you more in the
future
it's when you tell your kids tried and
true things around humanity and like how
people deal with each other that then
end up being true that starts to build
credibility and makes them listen to you
more the next time
yeah i'm like i'm stupid not to listen
to him i get it but i think even
flipping it like having my parents trust
me to
be able to talk in business meetings and
really
have my own career that i have a voice
in i think was something that made me
respect what they had to say so much
more because they trusted me and they
respected what i had to say i would
argue that what you just said is the
single thing that i spend the most time
thinking about how to make content
around because the counter to what you
just said is when parents pay for their
kids life
which directly tells that child that
that parent doesn't believe the kid can
stand another two feet
too many parents and you guys grew up in
neighborhoods around the tri-state area
that you're gonna know exactly what i'm
about to say because you saw it with
kids above your own kids while you were
watching as you were raising them just
like i did in most parents that care
about their kids
parents fear
for kids to be in situations that are
challenging has destroyed the kid
like like if you like
when when you were just talking charlie
i got so happy because it's the
opposite of what i'm scared about every
day which is parents continue to
overcoddle children
and what
what they think they're doing is helping
and what they're doing is they're
signaling to the kid i don't think
you're capable of doing [ __ ] without my
help which then renders that kid to not
be confident
yeah
you like yourself we talked about this i
won't tell the whole story because it's
kind of bad but
but there's like a time in high school
where i did something and figured it out
on my own but i never told them because
and um i told him recently he was like
well if i knew that i would have trusted
that you can handle yourself in
situations more like
i was
i was out doing things with my friends
and i was like yeah um so sorry about
that but i wanted to go to the thing
yeah of course of course no i wasn't
going to tell you
um but it's just like
a lot of times kids figure things out
and
it's the hardest balance because you sit
there and you want to give your kids
more than you had and you have all this
knowledge and you you want to protect
them every every every way and it is
it's detrimental and we've and i think
that's why people like all the kids are
so well grounded because as much as we
did that
we we did try to have them fall when
they on their own yeah
that was very important
yeah and for you you even had like the
double win of having an old older
sibling
and getting you know dixie was doing all
sorts of dumb [ __ ] you were like i don't
want to do that or i do want to do that
literally i took her along a little bit
yeah
but i think that that was very very
helpful and
made what i do now a lot easier even
from a young age so i'm very
appreciative of that well gang i
continue to cheer for you guys i really
appreciate you coming through i know
you're busy on this tour but i think for
me
i uh
i just really
think we're in a very unique time in
modern history
where
parenting and kid and parent dynamics
all these opportunities the internet
brings i actually think
that you guys in a lot of ways are the
preview not the anomaly i think we
touched on it it's micro it won't be at
the scale that you're at however
when everyone's like these well these
gen z's they're entitled i'm like they
understand their options you guys know
this intimately the average 17 year old
understands that she or he can make 60
000 a year
on youtube and tick tock and flipping
[ __ ] on you know on ebay and postmark
like instead of getting a job they
despise that's not entitlement that's
called being [ __ ] smart and so like
parenting and the way they view things i
think the college debt thing is a whole
[ __ ] to do and like
still staying parents and all this stuff
we touched on a lot of it here i'd like
to touch on it with you guys sometime in
the future even more because i think
i believe personally that when it's all
said and done you'll build a cpg empire
you'll sell albums and like get stars in
the hall and you'll lots of cool things
but i think the biggest legacy you guys
can leave
is actually impacting
this conversation because you're living
it and you're going through it in a way
that i admire because it's really
[ __ ] hard and i think these stories
that we touched on a little bit is
something at some point especially for
mom and dad that you need to really
think about because people are
struggling out there with this
conversation and they're blaming things
they'd rather blame tick tock and the
phone for their lack of strategic
parenting we lack accountability on the
subject matter from the kids level and
the parents level and i think you force
it in a very unique place to make a
massive impact on the world on this and
i will continue behind the scenes to
encourage you to make content around
this because you can really help people
it's awesome to do content that helps
people escape i really think
entertainment's super important like
watching someone dance watching a hulu
show like that 30 minutes that five
seconds that's important people have
complicated lives escapism is powerful
but thoughtful real conversations about
human dynamics that's how you change the
world in a positive way and i think you
have a lot of credibility in this arena
and are sitting with a lot of stuff in
your head and your stomach that you
haven't brought out yet and i i hope to
see you do that
see ya
[Music]